Brandon is in Ohio hey Brandon welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey Rachel
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I saw I kind of made a
dumb decision when I was uh three years
ago with my ex I'm getting married in
September so I'm trying to you know fix
out--there's and wrinkles so I co-signed
on a car for my ex and I ended up
letting them take it they repossess the
vehicle and everything and there's
eleven thousand dollars still owed on
the car I'm not sure if we should you
know worry about that right now or
because we have eight thousand dollars
saved up but we just wasn't sure if we
should tackle that or leave that for
later until they actually you know
pursue it
okay who's we my fiancee sorry oh oh I
see okay well she should not do anything
until she's married to you yeah yeah I
understand because that's why that's how
you got in this mess in the first place
yeah your act quick yeah so let me make
sure I understand the story right you
got divorced and then no you co-signed
for the girlfriend oh okay your ex is
your ex-girlfriend
so you co-signed for a car for your
girlfriend and then broke up then she
broke up with you or vice versa or
whatever and you've ended up and the car
ended up getting repo'd how long ago was
it repo'd yeah it was repo'd probably
maybe five or six months ago okay all
right so rule number one you said I did
a stupid thing that was what you said
okay and I agree with you that was
stupid
I've done a lot of stupid stuff in my
life as a matter of fact that's what
makes this show entertaining is all the
stupid things I've done in my life and
so the thing I always want to do after I
do something stupid is I really want to
say never again and so the rule
is never cosign alone for anyone ever
and have you thoroughly learned that
lesson now yes yes I will never ever go
down that road again so if you got a
little brother and little sister yeah I
got a little boy I need some help would
you co-sign for me Brandon I need a car
oh if you're a good brother yeah it's
gonna be it now okay $11,000 no I'm
sorry
girlfriends cars don't ever woman poor
fiancees like oh gosh yeah your fiance
is like so here's the deal
no you don't use your $8,000 to fix this
right now let it sit a little while
you'll you will end up having to settle
this at least you're part of it they can
go after your ex you and what I would do
is offer about 20 cents on the dollar so
if it's an $11,000 bill I'd offer him
about two grand and I would do that six
months from now when you get married
September 12th you might yeah so up
around Christmas or so call these people
up let them sit until then they
typically get none of this money that's
what they normally get zero so if you
say I don't really care about her
meaning the ex's name I don't care about
selling Joe all I care about is me I'll
settle my part you could still go after
her if you want I'll settle my part for
two thousand dollars and you'll have to
beat on them because they're gonna whine
and they're gonna act like they always
get more they usually get nothing and so
20 cents on the dollar we can usually
settle a repo for when our coaches our
counselors are working with people in
these situations because again the repo
come the companies on the repo deficit
usually get nothing nada and just
putting that in your debt snowball if
there's other debts that you guys are
working on yeah clear up your other
debts first just let that thing sit but
if you got $8,000 and you don't have any
other debt and you get married you still
got $8,000 you know then just call them
up and start trying to negotiate it may
take you two months
going back and forth with him just
messing with him so what if the average
percentage that they're gonna go after
her for the car versus what's the
likelihood almost zero because they knew
she wasn't worth the cost of a bag of
flour that's why they wanted a cosigner
they knew she was a deadbeat that's why
that's why they want to come in deputies
she said wait for it where do we get
work where we end up she got no she
didn't pay the bill the car got repo'd
so what do you call that deadbeat okay
so that's what you call that so yeah I
mean that's what's wrong
semantics now okay but I mean you know
she didn't pay the bill so that that's I
mean when I pay the bill a deadbeat so
yeah you know sometimes you're a
deadbeat that's what you do if you're
getting if you screw up your life so
girlfriend what if we don't know her
story what if she got in a lot of
trouble we don't know so I don't know
you're so sweet that's why people I
think you know you said think about the
whole picture how people like I think
about the whole picture give them the
benefit of the doubt
I got a dr. John de l'année fist pump in
the booth right now think about the
whole picture well it's right works
works but we're expanding our minds
Fanning our minds I'm just gonna she
didn't pay the bill car got repoed so
you can call what you want college
pretty soon that's it that's the facts
I didn't pay the bill house got
foreclosed on what do you call that
yeah call the guy got foreclosed on
because deadbeat also not a deadbeat
anymore quit doing stupid butt stuff so
there you go change the whole thing
your life was better growing up so there
we go